but our field five can take some time to
get used to especially if you're new to
the franchise or dipping your toes back
in after some time away it's not the
same beast as previous entries in the
series and features a lot of gameplay
elements that are unique to this title
so with that in mind I thought it'd be
worthwhile to throw together some tips
to help you and your squad out in
multiplayer I went into debt for this
point in my previous battlefield 5 video
death of the lone wolf but in
battlefield 5 it's even more important
than ever to stick with your team each
person has a role to fill and something
to offer the team beyond just racking up
kills and trying to shoot down aircraft
assaults are going to be best at
toppling fortifications and stopping
vehicles are they're sweet of explosives
medics are more efficient at reviving
fallen teammates and can keep the health
of their comrades topped up with
bandages and first-aid crates supports
are best at building cover and defenses
to establish a point of strength of the
team as well as supplying everyone with
oh so valuable ammo and laying down
blankets of suppressing fire with and
placed weapons and bipod mounted machine
guns and recons can do more than just
take the heads off advancing enemies of
the rifle since the changes in the
spotter mechanic in battlefield 5 their
spotting scope and flares are now a
hugely valuable tool to provide the
squad with actionable intelligence on
enemy player locations and a sneakily
placed spawn beacon can also allow a
squad to keep up a strong flanking
attack or provide a fallback point when
the squad is down remember the way to
win battlefield games is to PTF o play
the [ __ ] objective and while sticking
alongside your team and working as a key
Civ unit might not give you the best
chance to get those 6 300-meter
headshots from one end of the map to the
other it will keep you in the thick of
battle and more importantly give you the
best chance to win the game an extra
bonus to this is that you'll be earning
additional requisition points work
together and you'll be launching those
v2s in no time
if you've played battlefield 5 you'll
know the familiar sting of seeing a
medic or squad member close to you and
screaming out for a revive only to be
greeted with a respawn screen instead
now this isn't to defend those
absent-minded medics whose adrenaline
syringes seem to be about as useful as a
chocolate teapot since they never bloody
take them out of that bag
but more to encourage thoughtfulness
when it comes to picking up your pals if
there's a higher chance of you getting
shot during the revive rather than
actually saving someone then as morbid
as it is it might be best to leave your
comrade to their fate use your time to
distribute bandages throw down some
smokes build a barricade or even pick
someone else up instead if you're dead
sound getting someone up though you can
notify them of your intent by hitting
your mark button on their distraught
flailing form but bear in mind if your
buddy just got domed by a sniper and
they're on the open maybe don't rush to
revive them if someone is screaming for
help and machine-gun fire is already
cracking into the cover you're hiding
behind it might be wise to stay put we
all want to play the hero and save our
mates but if a revive attempts will get
you killed it's not worth it wait out
the seconds let them respawn on you and
then take the fight together it'll save
respawn tickets and a lot of time
hammering the spawn button
there'll be some moments in buffer 5
where you unlock a weapon and the first
time you use it it will have the
handling of an upset fish don't be
dissuaded by this your experience with
the weapon will improve as you use it
more I've seen people dismiss great
weapons in the game because admittedly
they're a bit pants when you first get
them but after a few rounds at a handful
of kills you'll start to unlock
specializations with them which changes
how they feel and how effective they are
put some thought into the weapons and
your play style if you prefer to stand
and shoot then you can make your weapon
work better in those scenarios if like
me you're a bit of a run-and-gun player
then you can make sure your weapon is
more responsive in quicker close combat
medics you can make your bullet hose
SMGs perform better at hip firing my
point is don't dismiss that sexy new
unlock because the first-year rounds let
your new rifle grow in you and develop
and unlock some more specializations
before giving in and going back to the
stone giver
[Music]
believe me fighting together is
imperative on the battlefield so being
able to actually communicate effectively
can turn a group of ragtag soldiers into
a fighting force of ass kickers and flag
takers believe me I understand that
actually using voice comms with random
folks you're playing with can be a
little intimidating I know your parents
probably said don't talk to strangers
the Internet but last time I checked my
mama's really [ __ ] at battlefield so I'm
not taking her advice on this subject
actually using your voice saves you the
need to keep spamming the spot button on
an enemy tanks location to try and draw
attention to the steel beasts instead
you'll be able to give clear and concise
information where it is where it's
looking if it has a top gunner if it's
taking damage and so on and so on and so
on it seems obvious but it's surprising
how much I group up with a random squad
and still feel a little isolated but
even if they're not talking back sharing
information that you have can help
everyone out if someone is getting
flanked or about to enter a building
full of enemy troops let them know we're
not actually in a time of loose lips
sink ships anymore chat to your
squaddies not only will it help you work
better as a team but there's been some
wonderful moments where I've made
friends with that badass medic who
dragged my ass up and got me back into
the fight if you expect your squad to
fight and die for you they're at least
worth of hello right
[Music]
vehicles don't feel like the
game-changing tools they're used to in
previous battlefield games
well I remember keeping an m1 Abrams
alive for entire games in battlefield 3
you have to be a bit more tactical with
tanks and planes in battlefield 5 tanks
really need a little support from the
folk trudging through the trenches
alongside them with their turret turn
speed being as slow as it is covered
Gunners having limited firing arcs and
Top Gun is basically sitting in a chair
that says shoot here being a good
teammate can really keep your team's
engines running by being a soldier that
keeps the enemy's heads down if your
tanks are taking panzerschreck shots to
the sides then try to push the cheeky
assaults firing them if you spied mines
on the ground then disarmed them with
grenades or gunshots if your squad
vehicle is taking fire spawn on it as a
support and give it a little touch up or
even if your bombers in the sky are
taking flak fire or are struggling
against dogfighting Spitfires do your
best to disable any ground guns or enemy
planes that are harassing your larger
aircraft helpful inventory can really
keep those ace pilots and tank drivers
ticking along which means that they can
in turn how buell by crunching armor and
levelling buildings filled with enemies
hopefully they return the favor next
round once you manage to actually get a
turn in the cockpit
so those are a few tips that should help
you wage a more effective war in
battlefield 5 and by no means the best
squad leader out there so if you have
any pro tips of your own that you want
to share feel free to drop them in the
comment section below or find me on
twitter at a regular dave and if you
ever see me in the battlefield I'd
appreciate it if you kept me topped up
with ammo and didn't laugh on my awful
flying skills thanks
[Music]